ladies and gentlemen welcome one of the
screens great adventure heroes Steven
Seagal
in Hollywood as we have come to learn
nothing is impossible nowhere is this
more vividly demonstrated than the lab
shop studios are the geniuses who create
visual effects here's a small example of
the work of the nominees in the three
films that earned them nominations for
visual effects in Forrest Gump nominees
Ken Ralston George Murphy Steven
Rosenbaum and Alan Hall were given the
task of removing the legs of actor Gary
Sinise instead of resorting to surgery
they had Gary where specially-designed
blue socks and removed the legs by
computer in masks starring Jim Carrey
nominees Scott Squires Steve Williams
Tom better Tina and John Bob Hawke used
their own remarkable artistry and their
crafted computers to create some truly
eye-popping special effects and True
Lies Arnold Schwarzenegger took to the
skies to do battle with the bad guys
using the largest green-screen stage
ever assembled
nominees John Bruno Thomas Fisher
Jacques straw eyes and Patrick McClung
digitally combined aerial footage these
sensational stunts to create those
references
and the Oscar goes to Ken Ralston George
Murphy Steven Rosenbaum and Alamo for
Forrest Gump yes
I'd like to thank the Academy it was
great being a film magician on gump
working for the amazing Bob Zemeckis I'd
also like to thank my wife Robyn Debby
Denise Vance Piper Pat Turner Mark
Holmes and of course and of course we'd
like to thank the incredible crew at ILM
that whose perseverance over the course
of nearly a year made Bob Zemeckis his
vision look absolutely real those guys
really did it we thank him especially
want to be sure to thank Doug Chang for
his fabulous art directions and putting
new words into the mouths of old
presidents John schlagg for his great
crowd control and antique Allen Cheney
for mining helping us mind our peas and
carrots and of course my wife Megan
Jones Charles newerth Joe Montenegro a
great special effects crew my wife
Suzanne and the creative mind of Bob
Zemeckis